est-ce que la menace russe s'était c'est
la mettre en avant
on peut effectivement se poser beaucoup
de questions à ce niveau là mais c'est
vrai que sur les inflexions que monsieur
macron a essayé de mettre en avant y
compris vis-à-vis de la russie
je parlais tout à l'heure de la question
de la confiance aujourd'hui
du côté de la diplomatie russe la vraie
question c'est est ce que on a quelque
chose à attendre de la diplomatie
française dans ce dialogue stratégique
au niveau européen et pour l'instant les
les premiers prémices de dialogue qui a
pu avoir n'ont pas donné grand chose
pour l'instant d'un côté comme de
l'autre et donc là la vraie menace
effectivement d'un point de vue
diplomatique c'est que américains et
russes s'entendent sur notre dos juste
pour finir sur cette question-là états
unis etats unis russie union européenne
on parlait tout à l'heure de la turquie
il faut quand même savoir que
l'opposition franche turquie donc j'en
parlais tout à l'heure ça a commencé à
se développer du côté du terrain
militaire en libye 1 sur les
affrontements en libye et quand la
situation sur le terrain s'est dégradée
notamment par rapport au trot dumas
rachat l'afpar et bien russe comme
américains ont joué notamment la turquie
contre l'union européenne contre la
france
donc oui effectivement il ya un jeu
géopolitique internationale où les
grandes puissances n'attendent pas la
france ni même l'union européenne
emmanuel macron dès l'année dernière à
parler d'autonomie stratégique de
l'union européenne c'est ce qu'il a
proposé notamment à l'allemagne
et là je suis d'accord que les allemands
peuvent entamer des dialogues un
dialogue à ce sujet y compris dans une
distanciation des allemands vis-à-vis
des américains y compris par rapport à
l'otan y compris même dans
l'establishment allemand par rapport à
la question du parapluie nucléaire par
exemple donc il ya un vrai début de
questionnements stratégiques en
allemagne sur toutes ces questions là
al'inverse comment faire pour faire
évoluer ces questions stratégiques
quand sur le terrain économique quand
sur le terrain économique les intérêts
de la france et de l'allemagne sont
divergents y compris par rapport aux
états unis et par rapport à la chine
oui
[Musique]